valentine's day is tomorrow we have one
hour to make something special for our
ladies i just gotta crash sam what are
you going through right now
we have a mere hour before our day has
ended today valentine's day is tomorrow
oh
have you guys gotten your significant
others a valentine's day gift yet i
thought it was next week
i was i was too distracted valentine's
day always sneaks up on me
always it is 5 30 and works fun at 6 30
and everybody goes home so we have one
hour one hour between now in the closing
corridor for all of us to make something
special for our ladies
we can't make something special in an
hour nico hey sam remember the beeple
challenge we did that was something
special in an hour we all did something
that was janky's specialness actually my
son he goes to daycare he makes art
every single day my wife loves them so
so maybe if they are kind of janky
they'll like them even more it's a
thought that counts guys the title of
this video is
vfx artists
save their relationships
can you vfx make someone fall in love
with you all of us
at the end of this hour
have to send our valentine's day image
to our sos
right now we need to pick the most
love-oriented 3d models that we already
have so we got to be efficient here
we're going all the same ones okay i
want like a really good plum
based object bullet
baby yoda baby on a baby or for sure uh
harrier jet tennis ball security booth
naked man body make a man
what i don't want to have to work with
that i got a heart we're gonna do a
heart guns guns anybody you want some
guns no okay flowers insects probably
flowers maybe it's not insects
okay guys i think that's that's all the
time we have you you said you want to
put a time limit on it we gotta go the
requirement is we have to use at least
one thing from that selection right
you're allowed to model your own assets
okay okay let's do it all right boys
let's get to your computer start your
screen caps we got 45 minutes starting
one minute here listen guys we gotta
make this happen let's all hold hands
encourage each other to do a good job
all right guys here's the middle and
you're just qualified if you don't send
it to your significant other by the time
this timer gets to zero that makes my
heart beat set up
[Applause]
i'm so slow
so my thought is we've been watching the
mandalorian my
baby daughter milo and baby yoda like
are basically the same thing right now
both in terms of cuteness and how they
express and emote i'm gonna do baby yoda
holding a bouquet of flowers nice and so
messed up
the texture's disappeared that's no good
[Music]
not cute at all i need a heart model and
the heart model asset whatever we
decided to grab it's not the right heart
element what do you mean it's not the
right heart element i wanted like the
classic valentine's day heart instead
there's an organ but i don't know how to
model in cinema 4d so i'm having to use
fusion
this is literally like the worst way to
model a heart is that is that what a
heart looks like
yeah dude
it's like a lily pad dude i
only have a small number of things i
need to do
i have to model a penguin
sam we included all these flowers and
they're all 3ds max files i don't have
3ds max i know you're on your own buddy
god dang it sam
[Music]
i don't have time for this cookie cutter
whatever okay fine
she's getting a cookie cutter she's
getting a cookie cutter see it just
camera's moved again oh it's probably
because there's key frames why is video
spinning
oh my god crashed
[Music]
35 minutes dude this is not happening
this isn't this isn't happening why is
baby yoda so ugly in this render model
somebody say baby yoda
uh-oh
excited to see what they come up with i
hope they don't get broken up with that
would be very sad on valentine's day
nico and sam are married so they could
get divorced which would suck
guys this isn't funny anymore this isn't
fun anymore guys guys let's get to
making a bouquet here i literally hit
control s and it closed the program
dude this flower is so small this flower
is so small my girlfriend broke over
oh that's it
baby yoda's 90 feet tall i'm like why
why are these assets i'm dropping in the
size of like grains of salt no it's
because my scale is completely off we're
at 24 minutes left 24 minutes that's
plenty of time
right
i just got to crash
we'll see if anyone actually comes up
with an image i i'm hitting save
constantly in preparation for crashes
like this i'm like
see what i'm dealing with here
what am i supposed to do
oh man i don't know
rip
okay
okay okay dean's following me now now
he's on board
oh 18 minutes guess what i had
this will be fun i'll just send my
girlfriend a blank text for valentine's
day no
oh dude that's rough you agreed to the
contest computer crashes and
my pen tablet wigging out i didn't agree
to those things guys look at the bright
side if we do a good job with this we
don't have to do anything else for
valentine's day
i'm gonna make this better
um
i need a witty phrase to throw in here
now i need a witty phrase what am i
gonna say clint you can't distract me
what is that
is this the idea you went in with it
originally or no no not at all 15
minutes
15 minutes yeah i got so much time it's
it's all like well and good to uh finish
your render ahead of time but what's
your wife gonna think of that that's why
i'm opening up after effects right now
oh
seems like wren has some tricks up his
sleeve crush the blacks
that's not racist that's the color
correction term that's a epic vfx time
yeah classic my computer crashed again
you know it's all about composition
that's what mr beeple told me so you got
to find a good composition i'm close
like i'm almost done i see the light
sorry did i just hear someone say they
want to know how much time is left
because it's 13.31 minutes
that's awesome looking
are you kidding me
dang it i got this janky ass looking
baby yoda
i just blue screen this is my submission
this is my submission
what
hey better something than nothing
there's like screen lines i know there's
screen lines on there what am i supposed
to do
maybe if i just like do you want to
your submission has to be a picture of
your vendor
there i'm going to edit it on my phone
god dang it
12 minutes how you feeling good i just
need to figure out how to do uh depth of
field again
oh geez man i'm going to lightroom god
that's unpleasant
oh jeez inside you're there
i need to
i need a better quote nick help me i
need i need a quote you helped people
with his quote yo duh i love you
that's pretty good
i'm totally totally keeping that all
right nine minutes
gotta be the final thing final touches
then
what's the dumbest thing and i it's kind
of amazing but it's so dumb you guys
remember that scene in spirited away
where she's like going through the
flowers it's kind of the vibes a little
bit right there
i can't believe it took a picture of my
screen before blue screen
that's the spirit of the contest
you guys have seven minutes to finish
export and send your photo to your loved
one and send you gotta send it i should
probably stop working on this and get to
finishing it is that it am i done
[Music]
am i done
what's render i think it's awesome i
love it this is exactly how i what i was
imagining in my mind
i am almost done
i'm very proud of myself for pulling
through despite the challenges here
let's go let's go let's go sign in now
sign in now let's do this let's do this
let's do this yeah wow sorry
sam that's really good
done rendered i think she'll appreciate
the pun
thanks nick it's just rendering
[Music]
[Music]
nice dude good job yo why didn't you
actually like make it uh better like why
didn't you let it render longer why
didn't you ah
two minutes and 40 seconds remaining oh
30.
how you guys doing how are you doing
great you're doing great hurry up nico
all right i'm done i'm done i'm just it
is what it is it's 43 543 i'm done
it's sent no i'm like should i put a
little bit more effort into mine
well when you're getting this close to
like the line here you have to be really
focused with what you add because you
can very easily very easily get way too
ambitious with what you're trying to
accomplish so
finishing 10 minutes early versus
finishing one minute early there's
almost no difference all right it's out
it's out it's out i sent it all right
everyone is sent yeah
you guys are awesome you have 44 seconds
to spare well let me make a second one
god
oh my god
sam what are you going through right now
i have context i sent it but you have to
realize that the way it appeared it
appeared like a response to her previous
texts which were a photo of my sick kid
passed out and then he just diarrheaed
so hard it shot up his front and back
and he nuked the couch and his llama
and then i said that happy early
valentine's day
are you serious let's see your picture
wow that's really good that's awesome
that's really really good
that's legitimately
actually good that's nice dude basically
i took all the flower models
i uh put a transparent material and i
cranked this setting called dispersion
which basically creates that
crystallized refraction effect on it but
i spent the entire time just trying to
do composition on it that was like
that was my big people
like uh takeaway which is
composition you're right we're here you
are my baby you are my baby happy
valentines that's cute baby yoda reminds
me a lot of milo they both kind of make
the same face like the
kind of thing
guys oh you got a response i got a
response smiley face smiley face my face
if it's for milo then you'd be spot on
well it's not it's for my dang wife
[Laughter]
all right
let's see yours
all right so let me preface by saying
[Laughter]
sorry i just i can't wait to see what
happened because i just heard screaming
the first half of this thing i might i
got two blue screens and three like
computer seizures so i didn't have time
to actually render the image so i did
have to take a picture of it with my
phone
and there you go you know that actually
turned out pretty damn that is pretty
good you guys know freaking artsy photos
nothing yep the white frame dude makes
it legit like the pictures give it a
pleasing like painterly effect you know
what i think he kind of lucked out there
for that crash all of your guys's were
pretty personal
mine has no personality whatsoever so
she probably like oh cool thanks dude is
this a stock image
probably 2.99 to download this jpeg
hey oh oh thanks beanie that was very
sweet of you
generic smiley face
all right you guys ready yeah yo
yo
oh my god you got peach fuzz reflection
like the the hi specular highlights did
jenna respond yeah
what'd she say
baby yoda and a pun a man after my own
heart wow that's some high praise i
think ren
may have just won the contest
i knew it i knew she'd appreciate the
pun that's totally my idea
you're welcome jenna
all right the day is safe guys well it's
6 30 it's time to go home here's what i
learned i almost gave up after the
second blue screen but then i realized
no i have to deliver something you can
do good stuff quickly if you just put
your mind to it and freak out hard
enough have you forgotten to give your
significant other something for
valentine's day you could go to the
corridor digital instagram where you
upload these pictures you look at them
in high res and you can screen cap them
and just send them off as if they're
your own except for mine unless you're
unless your girlfriend's name sarah or
your boyfriend i don't know i don't know
you guys named sarah hey one more thing
if for valentine's day you can give me a
present and that would be your
subscription that would make me really
happy
so you're saying you're saying it went
like this
yeah they have high pressure poop if
their diaper is a little tight in the
crotch it's like a skid mark on a dirt
bike where you hit the mud
and shoots
[Music]
up your nose oh yeah both nostrils
[Laughter]